what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren and today we're going to be
talking about charlie cox's matt murdock
aka daredevil appearing in spider-man no
way home because recently he's done
quite a few interviews and of course
they asked him about if he's going to be
returning as matt murdock in spider-man
no way home possibly appearing as peter
parker's lawyer and now we finally have
some sort of a response from him and it
makes us believe that he is indeed going
to be returning now right now obviously
there is a lot of talk about matt
murdock showing up in spider-man knowing
home not only does this just make sense
but a lot of plot leaks have said that
he's going to be returning as well and
one plot leak that you guys have heard
me say i know to be true a few times
does say that matt murdock is indeed
going to be peter parker's lawyer in the
beginning of the film as he's trying to
clear his name and this also just makes
sense the character fits perfectly to be
his lawyer that's what matt murdock is
not to mention we do have the echo
series coming up which is said to bring
back fisk and daredevil so this could
just be the tip of the iceberg if you
are a charlie cox matt murdock fan this
video is for you and if you're an mcu
fan be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel videos now
charlie cox doesn't actually have any of
the social medias he's not on twitter
instagram facebook he doesn't have any
of that however in a recent interview he
was asked if he sees everything that is
happening like when his name goes
trending and of course it goes trending
because of spider-man no way home now i
have three different interview clips
that are very important to see here one
is him talking about the rumors and
addressing them the other is about
whether that was his forearm in the
spiderman no way home trailer and the
final one is him straight up addressing
whether or not he's in spiderman no way
home or will be in the mcu in the future
and listen very carefully to what he has
to say here and listen to how he kind of
stumbles for his words thinking about
what he's supposed to say he's asked how
he feels when he sees his name trending
on twitter and he's asked how he feels
when people break down theories about
him being in spider-man no way home
so i'm not on social media so i don't i
don't i don't have the same awareness
about it as probably other people do but
obviously i hear about it you know my my
my mom will tell me about it and my wife
is aware of it all that kind of stuff
yeah i see it as a massive massive
it makes me feel very grateful that
people care that much
um
you know i
i also like
like it makes i you know i don't i don't
i i wouldn't want to ruin something
either way like yeah do you know what i
mean like so sure
so
it makes me a little anxious in that
regard
you know because
so it's a difficult you know so it's
difficult thing to talk about you know
all i would say is like
i guess
everyone myself included is just gonna
have to wait and see what happens so
when asked about spider-man no way home
he says i don't want to ruin anything
either way meaning he doesn't want to
ruin it if he's in it and he doesn't
want to ruin it if he's not in it but
then he says that it makes him a little
anxious and that it's a difficult thing
to talk about and he says that i guess
everybody himself included is going to
have to wait and see what happens this
is actually rather interesting language
that he's using because if you weren't
returning to the mcu if you weren't
coming back in spider-man no way home
you would simply state that you wouldn't
want to lead people on you wouldn't want
to give them any sort of false hope so
if the answer was absolutely no you
would simply say no this is kind of a
reverse of what andrew garfield has been
doing a lot of us believe him to be in
the movie there's a lot of evidence for
it but no matter what he straight up
says no i'm not in the film i'm not the
werewolf he sticks to one story even
though sometimes it gets a little not so
clear like when he says he hasn't seen a
photo and then he says oh i have seen it
but nonetheless he sticks to the same
story however charlie cox isn't really
picking aside he's not saying i am in it
but he's not saying he's not in it but
he has more to say and let's get to
these other clips so for those of you
who didn't catch this i'll just talk
about this real quick for those who
haven't seen it adam barnhart from
comicbook.com interviewed charlie cox
not too long ago and asked him if those
were his forearms in the beginning of
the trailer for spider-man no way home a
lot of us including myself did think
that this specific character could have
been charlie cox as matt murdock but
here's what charlie cox had to say i
have a picture of it right here so
charlie cox with the world as your
witness
are those your forearms i mean i've seen
forensic scientists
trying to break it down so i can promise
you
those are not my forearms
there you have it those forearms do not
belong to charlie cox mighty fine
forearms he has but those mighty five
arms they are not my thoughts
awesome charlie that is all i had for
you today man yeah thanks adam
and not to mention when the trailer
finally did come out in 4k and when it
came out on imax we did get a better
look at the face of that person and it
is indeed not charlie cox however with
that confirmation of the character we do
see that that is a detective and not a
lawyer his lawyer has not been revealed
yet in the trailers and the plot leaks
say that matt murdock is his lawyer and
check out this final interview clip this
was from just a few days ago charlie cox
is being asked if he's going to be
returning as matt murdock in spiderman
no way home in the mcu and he's also
asked if he just wants the answer to be
out there in the public already so he
doesn't have to worry about answering
the question and here's what he said and
pay very close attention to the end i'm
just conscious of when i'm asked about
it
you know
i i i don't want to
ruin anything for fans either way
you know
do you know what i mean so i just i i'm
my answer is i
i've no i i i no comment i don't know
what's going to happen i genuinely don't
know i also you know like um
if there was a chance of that happening
in the future
i don't want to say something that could
potentially jeopardize those chances you
know because
though the people are high up in marvel
maybe they see this stuff or they hear
what i say or blah blah blah or and
maybe that influences it i don't know i
have no idea but
you know i i i i don't i i love how
passionate the fans are and i feel very
very very
touched that so many of them have gone
online and made their voices heard about
their desire for me to come back and
maybe
maybe in the future that might happen
and that would be great so who knows
we'll see
so this is perhaps one of the most
interesting things that i have heard in
an interview before specifically a
marvel character being asked about
returning as that marvel character again
charlie cox says no comment after
stuttering a lot but then he says
something that i haven't really heard
somebody say before he says that if
there was a chance of that happening in
the future meaning him returning to the
mcu or spider-man their way home he
wouldn't want to say anything to
jeopardize that now if he's already in
spider-man know we home like we believe
him to be this is actually a pretty good
statement he is basically saying hey if
i am in it i'm not trying to say
anything to mess it up but of course
only him and a handful of people know
that he is indeed in it but again we go
back to the same issue if he was not in
the movie he would simply say he's not
in the movie because even if he did want
to be in it he could simply say hey no
i'm not in the movie i wish i was i
would love to return as matt murdock
that's pretty simple to say and you have
to think why wouldn't you just say that
if you're not in the movie you know he
claims that he doesn't want to ruin it
for fans but why would he give us false
hope why would he lead us to believe
that maybe he would be in the film if
he's not for a guy that seems to care
about the fans and i do believe that he
does i don't believe that he would lead
everybody on like that what i think this
is is a really good answer from somebody
who is indeed returning in the mcu and
in no way home but trying not to let
anybody know that he's returning like i
mentioned the one plot leak that has
been confirmed to be real from the
trailer because the plot leak was posted
months before the trailer came out and
then when the trailer came out we
actually saw scenes that were in the
plot league that the plot leaked
described well this plot leak said that
in the beginning peter parker is going
to go to court and matt murdock is his
lawyer not daredevil actually all of the
leaks that have come out about matt
murdock have said it's just matt murdock
and not actually daredevil combine this
with the fact that ekko is getting her
own spin-off series and the rumor is
that fisk and matt murdock are going to
be returning so we'll have daredevil and
kingpin according to the rumors it would
make sense that matt murdock would make
an appearance before that especially
since it fits so well they're both in
new york he is a lawyer peter parker
needs a lawyer matt murdock is a
superhero nobody knows but he does so it
would make sense that he would want to
defend another superhero and based off
of what he said in his interviews it
does seem like he is trying to hide the
fact that he is returning but what do
you think do you think the rumors and
plot leaks are true and charlie cox is
going to be returning as matt murdock
and spider-man knowing home and then
again in the mcu down the road or do you
think he's done let me know don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can always follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof